birth of the Dragon was directed by
george nolfi who made the Adjustment
Bureau in this film is about the
supposed fight that took place between
Bruce Lee and Wong Jack man in the 60s
in San Francisco when Lee challenged him
to a fight at this time in lee's life he
was training students in america to
learn kung fu and Wong Jack man isn't
entirely happy with that he feels that
kung fu is very much something to be
protected and not shared with other
cultures and this leads to their battle
now I was actually kind of excited for
this movie I enjoyed the Adjustment
Bureau I thought it was a pretty good
film a lot of fun and I'm a humongous
fan of kung fu movies I could watch kung
fu movies for hours on end for days on
end in fact I have Police Story with
Jackie Chan the mall sequence holy shit
legend of the drunken master -
specifically to the final fight one of
the best ever put the film fist of
legend anything really with Jet Li is
incredible if you watch his original
stuff when he was younger and of course
the iconic entered the Dragon I could
seriously watch conker movies forever I
love them and adore them and so I was
excited about the idea of a very legit
filmmaker taking on a Bruce Lee story I
didn't go into this film expecting a
biopic in fact the director has been
very upfront in interviews that this is
most certainly a fictional film that's
sort of centered around an event that
supposedly by legend happened and yet we
are seeing a film that has a lot of
fictional elements and that's one of the
biggest problems with this movie there's
a character in this film named Steve
he's one of Bruce Lee's students and for
whatever reason they choose to focus on
Steve so much that he essentially
becomes the main character of this movie
now look there's been all kinds of
accusations since this film premiered at
TIFF in 2016 and supposedly rumor has it
they re edited the film to have less of
Steve and more of Bruce Lee but watching
this film I'm not sure what they could
have cut because it still feels like
there's way too much of this guy I went
to this movie to see Bruce Lee and I
left having seen some really fun action
scenes a brilliant impersonation of
Bruce Lee
the actor who portrays him it's like
watching a reincarnated version of Li he
was amazing and the actor who portrays
Wong Jack man also I thought was
phenomenal
the problem with this movie is Steve and
it's not so much the actor I feel bad
for the actor I think anybody who is an
up-and-coming actor or somebody who
wanted to take a role like this would
take it they jump at the chance the
writing for his character is so
horrendously bland and for whatever
reason he's like the biggest thing in
this movie he has a crush that's it
that's it there's nothing else to his
character he wants to help this girl
that might be sold into prostitution and
he tries to get Bruce Lee to challenge
the master to a fight because the
prostitution house will be able to make
a lot of money on the bets that come in
from this match so basically every
little puzzle piece that comes together
for these two characters to fight is set
up by this Steve guy now yeah Bruce Lee
does challenge him once at a tournament
but beyond that it never would have
happened in this movie anyway if Steve
wouldn't step in constantly to try to
get in the way I could not stand this
character it's a baffling choice to me
that he's in this film so much when you
have someone who essentially is like the
reincarnated version of Bruce Lee in
this movie it was like watching it
actually kind of scratched an itch I've
had for years of seeing Bruce Lee kick
ass in a new movie the action scenes are
really good they actually are quite a
bit of fun and there's a lot of wide
shots really beautiful whites and
overuse of slow-mo sometimes though and
not quite enough movement I would have
liked to have seen more movement from
the camera like what Bill Pope did in
the matrix or his work in Scott Pilgrim
even had quite a bit of movement and
fluidity to his camerawork here there's
a lot of stationary whites and the
actors are doing such a good job and all
of the stunts are really really good
it's just that there wasn't quite enough
movement still it's entertaining
whenever the Bruce Lee character or Wong
Jack man are kicking ass or talking
about their ideologies and every time I
think the movie is about to get really
cool here comes good old Steve with
something to say and I'm like
dude get out of this movie why are you
here the problem with this movie was a
horrendous lack of focus they didn't
know where their story was they didn't
know where the meat of this story was
the climactic battle and some of the
action sequences in this film can kind
of make up for it you feel like you've
got a little bit of your money's worth
but in the end this probably shouldn't
have happened at least with this story
if they wanted to make a fictional story
surrounding an element of Bruce Lee's
life that supposedly happened because
they basically fictionalize everything
else if you are giving yourself that
much freedom as creators why would you
have some bland student character of
Lee's in the majority of this movie if
you're giving yourself that much
fictional freedom to tell whatever you
want to tell about Bruce Lee my god
what a weird choice I'm gonna give birth
of the Dragon a c-minus guys thank you
very much as always for watching I also
saw the movie good time this week with
Robert Pattinson
I'll have that review to you guys very
soon you're the best and if you like
this you can click right here and get
steppen eyes
[Music]